hello everyone and welcome to round 11
of the 1970 Palma de Majorca inter-zonal
tournament it's a game Bobby Fischer
with the white pieces faces left
Palgrave ski and as you've seen Bobby
after nicely executing five wins in a
row official drew two games then he lost
one game two bent Larsen and then again
he drew one game in the previous round
and now he faces left below Goreski
which aside from being one of the
strongest grandmasters in the world at
the time was also a really well known
open an opening theory specialist so
what do you do when you face an opening
theory specialist of course against
anyone Fischer will play e4 but for this
game he decided to play c4 so it's a
very interesting why I don't think
Fischer was actually afraid of Paula
gave ski being a better specialist at
the Sicilian and then Fischer as of
course follow guys he did reply with c5
to e4 but perhaps Fischer also didn't
want to you know polygraphs yes he was a
an opening specialist to play like
really well for example if you went for
the night of Sicilian and then Fischer
would have to refute it and then show
how to refute it of course the main goal
here is the challenge Spassky for the
title so perhaps he doesn't want to show
just you know how everything is done
just yet and I didn't find a photo of
this encounter in particular but we do
have one photo I found it's from the
1966 Havana Olympiad here Fischer faces
Boris Spassky so it's it's a game some
some six years before they will face
each other for the title but for the
photo challenge who are the two
gentlemen behind Bobby Fischer here so
best of luck to everyone now let's check
out this game like we said Fischer has
the white pieces and he opens with c4 we
have Knight to f6 g3 c6 so the English
opening is on the board
Bishop to g2 and the now d5 the core
account setup against the English
we have Knight to f3 Bishop to f5 and
here officially immediately challenges
this Bishop to a5 move with Queen to b3
saying that
the bishop should have remained there
and the b7 point is now under attack but
it's a it's a well-known line so it's
not a problem Queen to b6 immediately
going for the Queen exchange C capture
Sun d5 for Queen captures a captures and
pawn captures on d5 and light the c3 so
here fish responds and the B file are
doubled but in return he does get a
semi-open file for his a1 Brook so all
is well here Knight to c6
we're d3 and here is six by Palgrave ski
you might think before would be a very
nice move moving the night from a nice
square also preventing this pawn from
being pushed forward but actually not b5
well most likely we knew the game here
as the d4 pawn is attacked twice and the
knight to c7 is a threat winning the
rook so pretty much the only move that
deals with both threats is rock to d8
but now you have to face Knight to c7
check and after the King moves you can
simply move back and it's a it's a funny
square for the King you have to admit
but okay after d3 e six bipolar guess
keep opening up the bishop to be
developed we have castles by Fisher
Bishop to e7 and now Bishop to e3 again
a funny a funny move for the bishop but
a funny square for the bishop but it all
comes with a plan for example if
photographs q just castles here
then after Knight study for let's say
captures captures that the bishop is now
on d4 d5 is coming and this is basically
Fisher's plan but after Bishop to e3
ninth to g4 immediately coal gas he
attacks
bishops funny Fischer's funny plays
Bishop on e3 Bishop to f4 and now comes
the castles it's actually very often I
will say bush up instead of Fisher for
some reason we had efore as planned we
have pawn captures pawn captures and now
Bishop to g6 and here immediately a five
again seems like a funny move why would
you allow this bishop you know have such
a nice diagonal but it will you know
stifle position of stifled blacks
position quite well and this also opens
up Fisher's light square bishop so we
have Bishop to d3 again a very nice move
by polgár he could have just went Bishop
to see to for this b3 bond but he wants
to provoke rooked
and then worship the c2 will come with
tempo in case Fisher tried to stop this
by playing rock the c1 immediately and
do not allow bishop the c2 to attack the
b3 pawn then Bishop to c5 would have
been very strong now going after this f2
pawn this can be defended of course with
Knight the d1 attacking the defending
the pawn here I'm going after the bishop
and ephra Bishop to b6 it will be a nice
position to play but Fischer has a
different idea he plays rook to d1 we
have Bishop the c2 now with tempo look D
to C 1 now and only now bushroe capture
some v 3 and here comes Fischer's idea
he temporarily gives up this pawn to
have h3 now and h3 is a very nice move
because if you move the knight and there
is only one square where you can move
the knight that is h6 of course white
can capture but even better is nice to
d2 attacking the bishop here and after
the bishop moves you simply capture it
Knight captures captures and captures
and now you've won your pawn back g4 is
coming where you would pretty much trap
this night on h6 so white would have a
very nice position here so after h3
Apple guess it does not move the knight
rather he plays g5 we have H captors and
g5 g captures on f4 and now nights the
d2 attacking the bishop there and here
again a very nice move by Paul Gretzky
f3
so first deciding if you capture my
bishop on b3 I will capture yours ng -
so first Fischer captures but now comes
the Knight captures on e5 Apple ganske
manages to grab upon here and now if
Knight captures Bishop then Knight
captures Bishop on f3 would check so
fish removes the back and moves the
bishop back okay Bishop to d5 and now
comes Knight captures on d5 pawn
captures and Bishop and first rook to c7
so Fisher doesn't grab the pawn
immediately rather he goes for activity
and now the d5 pawn is under attack the
b7 pawn is under attack
the bishop on e7 is under attack so
Bishop to d8 attacking the rook and now
Rock after Sun b7 the d5 pawn is still
under attack
Bishop to b6 and the now comes the
Bishop captures and e5 Fischer finally
grabs upon but was
a mistake here are polygraphs he played
rook a to d8 and he attacked both the
bishop ended the night if the bishop
moves Fischer loses a whole piece here
so has Fischer blundered a piece here
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find a move that that saves both
of Fischer's pieces so I will give it a
couple of seconds as usual if you want
to decide whether to do it for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations for not blundering a
piece and for those who just want to
enjoy the show here Fischer played in 94
and now of course if rook captures
Knight to f6 check will pick up the rook
and the white wins the game here
so after Knight to e4 Knight captures on
g4 Paulo gasps he grabs the Jeep on we
have looked at d1 defending the bishop
and now comes King to g7 here you can
see that poll gas is night and Bishop
are eyeing the f2 pawn the night the
Fisher's knight on e4 is defending the
f2 point so black would really enjoy
playing f5 here at the kick await the
defender of the f2 pawn but he cannot do
it as the pony spin so first came to g7
and now rook to d2 now f5 will not be
such a big deal as the rook is also
guarding the f2 square we have Knight to
f6 offering a trade of knights
Federer accepts Knight capture screen
captures and now rope the d3 either
preparing to unpin the bishop would rook
to f3 check or perhaps to simply
exchange rooks we are rook to c4 or a4
King back to g7 and now King to g2 now
the F F pawn can be pushed and it is no
longer pinned rook to b8 offering a
trade of rooks so looked at d7 we have
looked back to d8 and now Bishop to c4
Fischer really likes his rook on the 7th
ranked rock after Sunday 7 rock capture
77 and King to g6 now we have G for
preventing black from pushing f5 and
also Bishop to d3 will be an idea but
here comes Rock to d8 polygraphs key
finds the the easiest way of you know
bringing this game to to an end
giving up the f7 pawn with check but it
doesn't matter Fischer plays Bishop
captures on f7 we have King to g5 and
now comes Rock capture 78 Bishop
captures on d8 and
it was in this position that they agreed
to a draw it doesn't matter that
fisheries up is up upon there's no way
to take advantage of this as the bishops
are of opposite colors so after this
point is defended regardless of in what
fashion for example f3 in defending the
pawn yes you do keep the extra pawn but
after Bishop to b6 and there's really no
way to make any progress here you could
play something like King g3 but you will
never be able to push f4 for example
Bishop c7 Czech king moves king to f4
now completely blocking those pawns and
after something like b3 putting the pawn
and a light square black will push h6
put it put his pawn and a dark square
and there's no way to take advantage of
the extra pawn in this position so yeah
after to d8 pegasi did give up a pawn
but it was only to secure a nice draw so
yeah that's a game from around 11:00 or
the 1970 palma de mallorca inter-zonal
tournament between robert james fisher
and the left Pulaski I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Tim and
Schreiber and the McCauley Polito for
contribution to my channel I thank you a
lot
I really appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
y'all for watching and I will see you
soon with another game from the Bobby
Fischer series about also today is the
final the final day of the first half of
the build tournament of the bill chess
festival so perhaps we'll show another
game from there thank you all and I'll
see you soon